[Music]
welcome everybody to the new speedrun
for those watching on YouTube uh we're
starting this at 300 a.m. it's February
the 8th and I know that I've been kind
of mentioning and implying a new
speedrun for quite a long time I know
that people are kind of getting
impatient for what's going to be next I
think this is going to be my fourth one
I I didn't want to rush the new speedrun
because wanted to develop a New Concept
and I wanted to make sure that the
instructive value does not drop kind of
like you know the value of a sequel and
then part three and part four I mean
that just tends to happen with anything
that starts off as as a popular thing so
I wanted to give it time I might
continue my old speedrun Frankfurt
airport for a couple more games I'm
going intersperse that with uh the new
one but without further Ado let me
explain in brief short terms what the
concept of the new speedrun is I can't
guarantee that you're going to like it
it's a bit of a difference from what
you've been watching with Frankfurt
airport and please feel free to be
completely honest in the YouTube
comments give me your honest feedback uh
so I know uh which direction to take
this uh if you like it let me know but
if you feel like this is not up to
instructional par tell me that as well I
all I want is honesty because if this
doesn't work out we can just go back to
like the 15minute format in short we are
going to revert back to the time control
of my very first speedrun which is 5
minute games the main reason for this is
that a lot of people there's a lot of
demand for improving your Blitz skills
this is a very popular time control and
I think that we can check that off the
list as well of course the downside is
that it is much harder to explain my
moves during the game and so this is why
I'm going to take a slightly different
approach uh and the overarching theme of
this speedrun is going to be to develop
your instincts what I'm going to try to
do what I'm going to tryy to gear the
games toward is helping explain um how
I'm able to react instinctively how I'm
able to make moves very quickly and
essentially try to extract the
subconscious process that contributes to
the vast majority of decisions that are
made in a Blitz game and sometimes to
decisions made in Rapid and even
classical chess you know that a lot goes
on in the very first like two or three
seconds or even less that look at a
position um particularly in Blitz and
developing those instincts that kind of
GPS is incredibly important in previous
speeduns I've really really tried to
kind of flesh out the process step by
step what I'm going to try to do in this
speedrun is talk a little bit less
during the games I'm going to make
relatively brief points and after the
game I'm going to try to hit on the most
important critical moments uh in the
game uh there might be like five or six
of them and I'm going to try to to
emphasize how I was able to make
relatively quick instinctual decisions
where were the critical moments in the
game if there was stuff to calculate I
will explain that as well so this is not
the only thing that I'm going to be
talking about but this is going to be
the kind of main theme of the speed as I
Envision it uh right now subject uh
subject to change so finally I did play
a couple of games on this account which
I've called hebecca raris for obvious
reasons my current 5- minute rating is
about 1,200
I did attempt earlier uh iterations of
the speedrun at a lower rating they
didn't work out particularly well so
we're going to start at a rating of
about 1,200 I know that some people like
to watch me go through the very beginner
ranks but I think this is a happy medium
where if you're a total beginner and
you're watching this I think you can
still learn a lot from uh games at this
rating I'm still somewhat provisional so
we're going to rise pretty quickly to
14500 um and we're going to spend a lot
of time at that kind of most popular
intermediate mediate level of course I'm
also going to play my main opening
repertoire uh everything I did in the
previous speedrun I'm not going to limit
myself but the goal in these YouTube
videos is going to be to play three or
four games um approximately depending on
length uh per video and the analysis
time per each game is going to be less
but hopefully that will be compensated
by uh the amount of games okay guys
without further Ado thank you for
listening to the rant to the speech but
uh for people watching on YouTube I hope
that makes sense and I will talk more
about the concepts in subsequent videos
but I know you're itching to watch me
play so let's go okay play Leo Yago 1298
um we are going to have essentially the
same repertoire as my previous speedrun
which was opening themed this will
hopefully help you acquire more practice
um with a couple of uh distinctions I'm
going to focus on the gleck uh the gleck
system against E4 E5 okay here of course
our opponent plays the the fidor
essentially the opening repertoire will
remain the same okay so against the
filor the main move is D4 but I really
like to start with Bishop C4 it's a
tricky little move our opponent responds
with H6 now we're going to open up the
center with D4 okay we're going to take
back with a knight and we're going to
continue our development maybe our
opponent wants to expand on the queen
side but that's not very scary because
they haven't developed anything
essentially we're going to keep
developing Knight E5 that hits the
bishop
I'm going to stay on the diagonal
already it feels like our opponent's in
big trouble because they haven't
prioritized uh development and we're
going to try to punish this so of course
I can play Bishop F4 and complete my
development but often the way to punish
this type of play is to kind of start
the pawn storm pretty early F4 super
tempting move just chasing away the
Knight and establishing the
preconditions for potential Pawn storm
on the king side all right now I'm going
to follow my gut and I'm going to play
the move Knight to F5 hopefully
initiating what I think is a very
favorable trade our opponent plays King
f8 let's grab the bishop pair okay now
we have an awesome position but we
haven't completed our development yet I
think this is a good time to do that so
let's go Bishop E3 and at this point
with the King being as weak as it is
with the pawn on D6 being a major
weakness and our opponent is still not
emphasizing his or her development so
it's a good time for us to start looking
for decisive tactics we're we're almost
there I think we need a little bit more
buildup uh before we could start
considering a move like E5 although on
second thought no on second thought
we're going to go E5 on second thought
we're going to go E5 yeah D5 our
opponent tries to keep the center closed
and my instinct here is definitely to
capture on D5 but here we need to do a
little bit of calculation so takes takes
Knight takes okay looks extremely
promising obviously
Queen let's see yeah um takes takes
Knight D5 Queen d8 Bishop C5 check King
E8 and we can sink our teeth into D6
yeah that's winning let's
go so as you can see I did a little bit
of calculation enough to give myself a
good sense but this is a very low stake
sacrifice we've only given away a piece
for two pawns so it's not like we need
to prove anything immediately I think
this is completely winning I just look
at look at Black's pieces he's playing
without a a queen side this is going to
be over in a couple moves Queen D7
doesn't really change what I want to do
let's give it a little
check okay now a very important moment
this Knight on E7 is the weakest piece
what's defending it well the queen is
defending it and the other Knight is
defending it which is the easier piece
to attack it seems to be the Knight on
G6 and so the logical move is F5 relying
on the very important tactical Det
detail that the bishop is pinning the
Knight this is over black is collapsing
on all fronts here Queen D5 okay our
opponent panics but there's not much to
do we just take back and the rest is
simple actually Bishop takes F5 Rook
takes F5 is really funny illustrates the
power of a pin yeah I mean look at this
the queen and the Rook are both hanging
my guess is our opponent will go like
King G8 or King E8 but then we can grab
the pawn on F7 Checkmate okay pretty
quick dirty there let's go through the
critical moments um now this was a
fairly straightforward game our opponent
played the filor bishop C4 is kind of my
recommended move against the fidor it's
it's very very flexible because if black
plays Knight F6 you can play D3 kind of
Italian style or you can play D4 and go
back into like main filor territory I've
had some games here uh in the previous
speed onun H6 is already
inaccurate and clearly the response
should be to open up the Center our
opponent uh takes on D4 wait let me
refresh the board Knight takes D4 C6
Knight C3 already we have three pieces
developed our opponent has zero Knight
D7 so here I'm just developing Knight E5
Bishop B3 one point for newer players is
anytime you have a bishop on B3 like
this you have to be careful about you
know these various tricks and traps
where essentially a pawn advances to C4
A4 and traps the bishop the most famous
instance of this is the Noah's zark trap
uh the Noah's Arc trap can manifest
itself in several different ways but the
most famous is in the steinet uh the
defer steinet variation of the R Lopez
if white plays the move d4 black
responds with B5 Bishop B3 Knight takes
D4 and in this position it's a huge
mistake to play Queen takes D4 because
black pushes C5 and you should be you
should see what's going on no pawn and
see what's going on Pawn is advancing to
C4 white can try to counterpose this by
attacking The Rook but unfortunately the
bishop comes out with Tempo check back
Queen D5 looks like a draw nope because
now The Rook is defended and black
pushes C4 a lot of strong players have
fallen for this but in in the game
position C5 is could not be less scary
there's a million ways to face this it's
also an extremely weakening move the
simplest is just to go Knight F5 and C4
Bishop drops into A4 D6 is collapsing
this is is not scary Bishop E7 chasing
away the Knight with F4 now the move
Knight F5 Bishop F5 e takes F5 I didn't
calculate this position I just assume
that we get the bishop pair we get the E
file and the Knight on G6 is no good
squares because if Knight H4 then it
could get trapped if Knight back to f8
just look at this position this is a
disaster Rook e one Queen H5 uh there's
a million moves here King f8 Knight
takes E7 grab the bishop pair Bishop D3
complete the development H5 is another
meaningless move and this was maybe the
most important moment in the game how
did I quickly and instinctively decide
on the Move E5 well the basic premise
here is that Black's position is in
shambles we have a huge lead in
development the textbook way to punish
that is by opening up the center and E5
is the easiest way to do that if black
plays D takes E5 who can tell me the
specific move that I had in mind here
with white and don't tell me Bishop C5
because Queen C5 is a check I know that
a lot of you are probably thinking this
there's a couple of moves that I liked
here what do you think is the most
accurate if you're watching on YouTube
Just pause for a second and think about
it so the move that I intended and maybe
it's not the best the move that I
intended to play is Knight E4 this is
the move that I intended to play what
does this threaten this threatens Bishop
C5 and this is what I call the Ros and
bites idea um this is a very common idea
where you push the pawn and then then
put a piece on the Square that was
vacated by that pawn uh because often
that square is Prime real estate on the
board I've shown this example a million
times but here it is once again um this
is kind of a textbook game that's been
featured in some books Rosen versus
Bates this is the critical position what
did white do uh after
H6 who can give me the entire sequence
so if you're not familiar with the
concept your instinct is probably to
play Bishop H4 like why would we give up
the bishop and give black the dark
squares but if you know the concept you
understand that Bishop F6 is the preface
and now there's a brilliant idea what is
it it's E5 it's E5 D takes E5 and Knight
E4 same thing and this works tactically
because if black takes we take on F6
with that's a check black loses the rook
and once the bishop moves just look at
how beautiful this position is this
Knight on for is dominant the king side
is collapsing in white one uh very very
quickly okay so let's go back to the
game yeah what I'm saying is black can
respond here with B6 but after F takes
E5 Knight takes E5 white can probably
win this in a million different
ways essentially choose your pick but
the takeaway here and our opponent
allowed the sack which I think is very
very clearly totally devastating just
look at this position it should be very
clear to you even if you're newer player
that this is completely overwhelming
just because you know everything is
coming in so one important thing is that
behind a lot of these instinctual
decisions is pattern recognition so like
knowledge of this concept that's exactly
what pattern recognition is but it's not
this mythical idea it's something that
can be developed a by solving a ton of
tactics and B by keeping your eyes open
for instructive games and instructive
Concepts any questions is it clear to
people let me pull the twitch chat that
this position is winning is it
intuitively clear looking at this
position that you should be winning here
yes it it is okay good next game black
against Rami I think we're going to play
probably three three games in the
speedrun okay let's go
E5 let's go Knight C6 this is the nimich
Larson uh Knight F3 okay so this is
actually the modern the modern way to
play um we respond with E4 this is
theory
the old move by the way is uh is A3 uh
is E3 and I'll talk a little bit about
this after the game so here again
there's a little bit of specific theory
that you should know uh in this line but
the important thing is that you always
play D take C6 uh in this position you
don't capture toward the center you
capture away from the center of course
in order to open up the bishop and in
order to open up the queen exerting
together with the E Pawn great control
over the center now the dark squared
Bishop typ ially comes out to D6 and you
might say well doesn't this kind of
counteract the influence of the queen
well yes but the bishop on D6 is aiming
at H2 in case White Castles King's side
there won't be a Greek gift sacrifice
but there might be the preconditions for
a later tactic and the queen is going to
come out to E7 this is how we're going
to set up our pieces let's go Queen E7
white is very likely to push D3 at some
point or D4 but black has a great
position here it's about equal it's
about equal
F3
let's take
it Rook takes F3 whoa okay our opponent
playing very Loosey Goosey here very
Loosey Goosey I am going to go Knight to
G4 attacking the H Pawn trying to
provoke another weakness on the king
side and then the Knight drops back to
to
E5 of course white can also play G3 but
that's potentially even more weakening I
think we might have some tactics there
um Rook F2 okay that's clearly a
panicked reaction
but once you that you're this close to
winning it's important to for a second
and TR to be accurate because then uh
you take away the possibility that your
opponent you know kind of stays in the
game and eventually pulls off A Swindle
so obviously we need to take on H2 first
now we can probably take the Rook we
have other moves but I don't really see
a reason to be fancy here I think we can
just go directly for checkmate let's get
our Queen involved with a check and
let's set up uh some mating patterns
with Bishop G three setting up the
threat of Queen H1 this is kind of a
very very common construction white has
to move the bishop out it's not totally
over yet Bishop F3 that's a bad move
though this allows Checkmate in two
moves and it's very fitting that our
final piece comes out with Checkmate I
really like when that happens now this
was an easy game because white just
didn't handle the opening properly now
the nimzovich Larsson is not a bad
opening it's it's kind of a Ki opening
uh that's seen quite a bit of
development in recent years there's a
good chessable course on it by aibon I
would not recommend it to the vast
majority of like beginner and
intermediate players uh because you're
not developing the right kinds of skills
in order to play this opening
successfully you have to understand how
to properly like violate the rules give
up the center and you have to know a lot
of theory just because there is a player
who's been successful in a line doesn't
necessarily mean that you should you
should play it so here the main move is
E3 and I won't delve too deeply into
this into this move black has many ways
to respond to this uh the most common is
Knight F6 Bishop B5 and now this weird
looking move Bishop to
D6 uh which may strike you as extremely
awkward because it buries the bishop on
C8 but the logic behind this move is
that for instance after Knight E2 A6
white is going to have to play Bishop
takes C6 there's no other choice because
after Bishop C4 we literally trap the
bishop and now we hit the Rook here okay
so here what white has to take on C6 and
much like in the game we play D take C6
and everything is everything is is
copacetic in this game we Face the kind
of modern move which is Knight F3 we
respond with E4 Knight D4 and we just
develop our pieces Knight F6 so we
actually want we want white to play
Knight takes C6 as you could see in the
game this gives us fantastic development
it opens up the bishop and it opens up
the center which is in our favor because
we control a bit bigger share of it and
we have better develop
okay Bishop D6 should be logical to you
Bishop B2 castles castles Queen E7 why
did we play this move to prepare rook d8
and to solidify the E Pawn F3 is already
the beginning of the end it's a very
very weakening move I think white should
have played D3 uh to which we probably
would have still responded Rook to to d8
or Bishop to F5 so instead F3 e takes F3
definitely white should have taken with
the bishop white played Rook takes F3
and now Knight G4 this was the main
instinctive decision that won us the
game how did I make it so quickly well
it should be a pretty intuitive move to
because the the risk to reward ratio is
extremely positive this is not a risky
move we're not sacking anything the
Knight can drop back to E5 but what
we're doing is we're provoking very
serious weakness on the king side if
White had played H3 we drop the Knight
back to an excellent centralized Square
we are never afraid that white trades
because this gives up White's main
bishop and essentially loses the game
now if white drops back to F1 we can
start accumulating and assembling our
other pieces on the king side and trying
to use the holes that we have created
such as with a move like Queen to G5 now
we're threatening Bishop takes H3 and
already white is in huge trouble even
Queen H4 although Queen H4 may be Queen
E1 so I really like Queen Queen to G5
even Bishop takes H3 can be considered
but I wouldn't do something like that so
the idea of provoking weaknesses is um
particularly for new players something
that you should pay attention to a move
like Knight G4 the point is not to go
directly for checkmate it's it's to
weaken squares that later on our attack
is more effective in addition I was a
little bit worried about the prospect
that white would take on F6 I I said
didn't you just say that white we are
never afraid of this no here obviously
this is a different story I don't think
that black is worse here why allow this
to happen any questions about this game
simple game after white played Rook F2
the rest was a matter of technique uh
don't automatically capture pieces when
you get excited take a moment because
there might be a better move what if he
plays Knight G5 instead of Knight C4 oh
question about the opening well Knight
G5 blenders the Knight yeah so this is a
pretty forcing line there's more Theory
here but I'm sure we'll get another
chance to to talk about this let's keep
going I'll probably one more game for
now playing a 1300 and we do cross 1300
with this game all right so I will go
for the king Indian from the very
beginning this time I think people will
like this bishop to G5 that's kind of a
sideline and it doesn't really change
our reaction we're going to go D6 for
starters and there's many ways of facing
this variation this is called the smithl
variation uh it's a decent line there's
nothing much to say about it I'm going
to Castle I'm going to play this in the
simplest possible way another five subs
from Mr
bortnik and we're going to play the move
C5 contesting the center trying to open
up the diagonal for our Bishop Bishop to
E2 we're going to develop our Knight
White Castles I have to say our opponent
is playing the opening quite well now
we're going to complete our development
with Bishop F5 again the the way that I
am playing this with black is not
necessarily what I would do in a
classical game it's just a decent setup
uh that's pretty easy to play
A3 okay A3
A3 okay many tempting ways that we can
play this with black many many tempting
ways that we could play this here's what
we're going to do I don't know what
we're going to do yet we're going to
start with G5 we're going to chase away
the bishop and now we're going to put
the Knight on e4 and this move Knight to
E4 this trade is very very common in
King's Indian positions because what we
have achieved number one is that we have
cleared the obstacles for our dark
squirt Bishop which is now extremely
strong the other main thing is that we
have loosened White's control over the
center again our opponent is handl this
extremely well if we play Knight to A5
we might run into B4 so we're going to
reroute the Knight back back around to
D7 we can ignore the attack on B7 it's a
false attack Rook a D1 and now we're
going to start operations on the queen
side let's begin by playing the move A6
and preparing B5 like Knight D2 we drop
the bishop back always to G6 in these
types of positions Bishop F3 and I think
it's a great time for us to open up the
the queen side with B5 takes takes okay
he doesn't take now we're going to put a
rook on B8 continuing the pressure down
the B file our Knight can also jump into
E5 at some point yeah definitely white
is underrated by a bit but the game is
starting to turn in our favor now we
play B takes C4 opening up the file and
now do we want to take this bishop it's
not a bad idea but actually I am going
to let them our opponent take on G6 why
do I do that for a very simple reason
we're opening up the f file and I'm
already looking at these two Rooks I'm
already looking at this F Pawn because
the Knight is very very likely to move
at some point and I'm again trying to
create the preconditions for some sort
of an attack down the second rank now
which piece is not playing here clearly
the queen we have an excellent Square on
A5 also because it attacks the Knight
okay we're close to winning now we're up
a pawn and at this level people collapse
very very quickly when when you when you
put this much pressure and they already
feel like the game is going down the
toilet a blunder often ensues this is
GG Rook C1 there's a million ways of
winning this position but I see a way to
force the queen trade uh which is to
play Knight B6 contact between pieces I
talk about this at length anytime one of
your pieces makes contact with one of
your opponent's pieces it sounds like a
very primitive point but it's actually
very Central to uh consistent tactical
Vision particularly if it's a situ
pieces that's
aec it Doan's going to be you should
automatically consider the idea that
okay if I chase away the Queen White is
going to have a hard time keeping the
Rook protected now we can exchange we
can take either Pawn let's take D5 the
center pawn and okay now white blers the
rook and the game is over okay fantastic
now in the previous speedrun I didn't
start out by playing the Kings Indian I
was playing the grunfeld
I still think that grunfeld is a great
decision in this speed I've decided to
play my actual repertoire and my
recommendation for people who want to
learn the Kings Indian want to learn
openings in this speedrun is to pay more
attention to the way I'm playing rather
than getting to bogged down in
theory particularly with the Kings
Indian which is an opening that yes has
a lot of theory but you also have to
develop great instincts for how to play
it um if you understand the ideas of the
Kings Indian even if you know zero
Theory you can actually play it very
very decently just if you understand the
setups and why the pieces are where they
are okay so Bishop G5 D6 Knight F3
castles and E3 the one important point
that I will make in this game in this
analysis is that in the Kings Indian
there are essentially two ways to strike
at the center there's C5 which we played
in this game which is kind of the more
Bon style move and there's of course E5
which is the more traditional King's
Indian way to play but a lot of people
they assume that E5 has to be played
that they are morally obligated in every
position to prepare E5 and there are
many situations where stubbornly trying
to play E5 is actually not a great idea
uh here it blunders the pawn takes takes
a knight E5 but even if you prepare it
with a move like Knight bd7 I am not the
biggest fan of this setup because it
justifies the placement of White's
Bishop so here it makes perfect sense
for us to play C5 there's another idea
here which is that anytime white pushes
D5 this diagonal is open and the B2 Pawn
is going to be a long-term weakness
because white has developed the bishop
to G5 there's also maybe a Kings Indian
course on cheso that will be coming out
some point in the near future um another
great example of a line in which you
don't want to play E5 is the aack
variation where white plays Bishop B2
and then Bishop to G5 this is another
instance where the main move here and
the top engine move is C5
why is E5 bad here if you're watching on
YouTube great opportunity to pause and
start developing your understanding by
refuting this move E5 essentially loses
the
game why yes so takes takes takes the
queen takes the queen and Knight to D5
and black is in huge trouble this is
actually just a fork that's all it is is
just a fork if you take you drop the
exchange and the only move here I think
is yeah that's basically the only thing
you can do yeah black is busted I mean
Knight bd7 you can play but you drop a
pawn and it's a terrible position okay
so here again you want to play C5 so the
takea away from this first King's Indian
game is that you should be flexible to
pushing E5 pushing C5 and you should
Rush neither of these moves sometimes
you can play it without making one of
these moves for a long time C5 Knight
C6 uh also you're not really afraid in
most cases of the move D5 this Knight
can go to a variety of different places
often you want to play Knight A5
flouting the rule about Knights on the
rim because the Knight on A5 is actually
not a bad piece here hitting C4 and it's
part of a larger Campaign Of Queens side
expansion we'll put that aside for now I
threw in the move H6 just to make the
bishop decide on a spot completing our
development G5 why did I play this to
force the bishop onto a bad Square um
this is a move that will be hard to play
for a lot of newer players CU you are
weakening your king but we are so active
here that I really wasn't worried about
anything happening and when you have a
fto bishop you can often allow yourself
kind of more Liberties uh with your
kingside Pawn structure and once the
trade happens we're already threatening
to win the D4 Pawn by taking the Knight
and playing C takes D4 so we're
essentially forcing white to push D5
here we drop back to B8 there was a
tactic that we had to avoid after Knight
A5 white has the move B4 and you might
might say but wait a second we just take
the Rook but once white takes the bishop
not only have we given up the dark squ
Bishop but we're actually also losing
the Knight Knight B3 Queen B2 the Knight
is trapped okay so this is something to
watch for Anytime the Knight is on A5 or
H5 you have to be vigilant about moves
like B4 so therefore we drop the Knight
back to its initial Square in order to
reroute it around to D7 Queen B3 was
pretty bad move of course we're not
afraid of this this should be pretty
intuitively clear to you white is just
like collapsing here the queen could get
trapped this is fantastic compensation
for the pawn Rook A1 A6 again simply
following what I know right so you might
be looking at this and saying how did I
play A6 B5 so quickly this is a textbook
idea I me this Pawn structure this is a
pawn structure that can occur in the B
Gambit for instance which is the most
direct way to get this play and
sacrifice the pawn and if you know
anything about the Beno Gambit you know
that the idea is to sack the pawn to
ultimately open up these queenside files
and develop play and the Kings Indian is
like the English language I think it's
it's referred to as the zombie language
sometimes because it like eats other
languages what I love about the Kings
Indian is that it's a very flexible
opening and therefore it borrows a lot
of ideas from other openings and it
really helps develop your your overall
understanding uh so one of those ideas
is to prepare this campaign of Queens
side expion with the ultimate aim of
opening up the B file and going after
the B2 Pawn um often yeah so B5 this is
not actually a sacrifice if white takes
it twice we just play Rook B8 and we win
the pawn back so this is not really a
sacrifice but our opponent kind of
ignored everything that was happening
and after B takes E4 the game is
essentially over we infiltrate with Rook
takes B2 notice that I left the Bishops
where they are to open up the f file for
our other Rook if white would have
captured on A6 which is probably the
correct move there's a million things
that black can do we can play Queen A8
to try to get the Queens off the board
we can play H5 um and try to kick the
bishop away there's a million different
moves Queen A5 getting the queen out
white is collapsing and our opponent
blundered the Knight Knight E4 we can
play Knight B6 we can play Knight E5
there's a million possible moves here
black is much much better one
recommendation for people watching this
yes the analysis is a little bit more
sparse but as I explained at the start
this is kind of the point I'm trying to
give you the kind of big view of the
game and why I make the decisions that I
make if you come across something and
you're confused about why I'm saying a
particular position is good or bad set
it up yourself and spend a little bit of
time analyzing with the engine okay this
is an opportunity for you to further
your understanding and just kind of
looking at positions in an open-ended
fashion is exactly how you improve right
so I would if you want to be truly
diligent mark down the moments where
you're kind of confused about something
and then spend 5 10 minutes analyzing
that position this is not just a case of
me being lazy Active Learning is
extremely important in chess I can't
feed you everything with a you know with
a spoon you have to acquire certain
knowledge yourself so we win our first
Kings Indian game nothing to talk about
after we take the Knight and I think
this is a good spot to end guys so this
was the first video of the new speedrun
please uh it was a little bit on the
shorter side if uh you like this format
and you want me to continue uh the next
videos will be longer please give me
your honest feedback in the comments and
I hope you guys enjoyed welcome to the
new speedrun we're definitely going to
play more interesting games and uh give
me give me your honest opinion I can
always revert back to the old format um
but for now thanks everybody and I hope
you guys enjoyed this stream this was a
long one I'm going to get some rest
thanks
[Music]
guys